Hi, I'm Dr. Clark.
You know that great mood you get from your daily workout?
Here's an easy way to ratchet up those feel-good feelings a notch or two.
Invite a friend.
One study suggests that exercising with a fitness-minded buddy is more fun...
...and boosts the level of happy chemicals, endorphins, your body produces when you exercise.
Research has shown for years that exercise helps improve people's mood...
...because it boosts the level of endorphins in your body.
This study, which focused on university crew team members,...
...showed that 45-minute workouts done in groups helped increase the rowers' pain threshold...
...and their endorphin levels better than when they exercised alone.
But you don't have to join a team to benefit from the buddy system.
Just invite a friend to join you on a walk or a run.
Or schedule a date with a pal to do a circuit at the gym.
You'll both feel better for it.
For more ways to make exercise fun, watch all our Smart Tips right here.